Okay today we're going to introduce a
new concept that is going to help you
understand the economy of today and the economy
of the future, it is called 'The Asset Economy'
all right so one of the biggest changes in the
economy in the last 20-30 years has been an
enormous increase in asset prices that is most
visible in house prices but it's important to
understand that it's actually happened in pretty
much all assets; there's been a massive increase
in stock prices, there's been a massive increase
in land prices, there's been a massive increase
in the gold price and while I'm filming this in
London there's been a lot of focus in the UK on
London; it's important to realise that increase has
been pretty much International we've seen a big
increase in house prices and stock prices all
overEurope, the U.S, all over the Western World
now this is what I call 'the Asset Economy' the reason
I callit this is because asset prices have increased
enormously in the last 30 years and wages have
only increased a bit we have moved into a new kind
of economy where increasingly the work that you
do is not really that important for determining
how rich you are, increasingly the only thing that
matters is how many assets your family has
I think the best way to explain this is probably
throughgiving an example so if you are living
here in London and you make £70-80,000 so you
know 2-3 times average income so you've got a
really good job, a really good wage, increasingly it is
almost impossible to buy property without being
able to get some significant help from your family
unless you can get a big cash gift from your
parents or at the very least have a long period of
staying with your parents and not having to pay rent
on the flip side if you are from a very wealthy
family what you will see is even if you have
a pretty average paying job £20-30,000 a lotof
people from those kinds of families can quite
easily buy property because they can get big gifts;
half a million pounds, £600,000 from their family
so what that means is increasingly we'rein a
situation where basically for determining how
rich you are the kind of job you have the kind of
degree you have increasingly doesn't really matter
all that really happens all that really matters
is how many assets your family has so we're
moving away from an economy where your financial
outcomes for you as an individual for your family
were primarily determined by your job and your
salary and we've moved towards an economy where
the financial outcomes for individuals are
increasingly overwhelmingly determined by
the amount of assets a family has now in other
videos I've referred to this concept as the end
of capitalism what I mean when I say that was my
parents and my grandparents they lived in a world
where really regardless of your background if you
are willing and able to work really hard you could
save up some money buy a house if you're willing
to work really really hard you can even get rich
increasingly for my generation and for future
generations, that will be impossible, so we've
moved away from this kind of capitalistic idea
of meritocracy, work hard get rich, we're moving
towards really an economy which is primarilyabout
inherited wealth I've called this 'a New Feudalism'
we're moving into an economy which is anasset
economy you can only be rich if you are bornrich
if you are born poor you will definitelydie
poor, now in my opinion this is the biggest
economic trend of the last 20-30 years
it'sgoing to continue so if you want to
understand the economy of today and the future
you need tounderstand the asset economy
next step; how did we get here? how did
we move into an asset economy?
now this is actually what I wrote my thesis on
this when I was at Oxford this is actually
the thing I've looked at most of my time as an
economist so it's something I'm really interestedin,
I'm really happy to be able to explain it
the reason that we've moved into an asset
economyis because of the massive increase
in wealthinequality in the lastThirty years
this has happenedfor a few different reasons
the three main reasonsI would point out is
number one: massive decreasesin the
effective tax rates of the very rich inthe 80's
under the Thatcher government here inthe UK
and the Reagan government in the 80's (*U.S.)
(No.2*) the increased integration between Western
economies like UK, Europe, US and much more
unequal economies like India or particularly China
and thirdly the mismanagement of massive crises
like the 2008 crisis and the covid crisis in such
a way that they led to massive increases in wealth
for the very rich and that's something I've
talked about a lot on this channel so once you
have a massive increase in the wealth of the very
rich what that means is you get a very rich class
that has a huge amount of assets and they have
huge amounts of passive income so we always
use as our example Rishi Sunak; he's worth about
£700million to £800 million, he will generatea
passive income every year of something like
£20-30 million, very rich people with big passive
incomes they tend to use the vast majority of
those incomes to buy the rest of the assets
what that means is all of this money trying
to buy assets, it pushes asset prices up
those super rich buy the assets of the middle
class which makes them even richer which
pushes asset prices up even more so because
ofthe dynamics of this, once the rich getvery
rich they buy more assets which makes them
richer, which means they buy more assets still
what you get is a spiralling nature so the rich will
get richer and over time the middle class will
increasingly lose their assets which means asset
price will go up and up and up, wage will go down
and down if you want to know more about this you
can watch our video how wealth inequality affects
the economy but the primary thing you need
to understand is once the rich get very rich
asset prices go up, ordinary families lose their
wealth and this gets worse and worse over time
so understanding the asset economy will help you
predict the future because the asset economy is
going to be more and more what the future looks
like part three what does the asset economy mean
for you for your family so I think the number one
consequence of an asset economy is that upward
social mobility becomes almost impossible and the
reason for that is quite obvious right because
as asset prices go up and up and up andup and up
much faster than your wages it simply becomes
impossible to buy assets with your wages and
that means that unless you already have assets
you can't get assets now when I say social
mobility is impossible what I mean is it's
basically impossible to move upwards in class so
if you look at a very small scale if you consider
two people from very poor families if one of them
gets a 30 grand a year job and one of them gets a
60 grand a year job that person with a much higher
salary will be able to live a more comfortablelife
but it will not be enough to be able tobuy
assets and move up into a permanently higher
asset owning position for them and their
family in the long run so if we only look at
ourselves and people in a very similar situation
to us it looks like a meritocracy but once you
start looking at yourself and people born with
higher wealth you realise it becomes impossible
to move up so upward social mobility basically
ceases to exist and you're already seeing this
massively now when I look at the people around
me in my life almost everybody my age is pretty
much the exact same position in the financial
hierarchy as their parents were and that is
because the most important thing that matters
iswhat assets you inherit from your parents
the other side is okay if upwards social mobilityis
impossible what about downward social mobility
well what happens when you have an asset
economy is that asset prices go up and up and
up and up, we still do have a decentlysized
property owning middle class in thiscountry
country it's largely older people and these
older people find themselves in a situation
where there is a massive financial incentive
for them to sell their assets because they're
sitting on a house that might be worth 500 600
grand, living is becoming more difficult so if
they sell that property they can have a much
more comfortable retirement they can they can
it looks like they can support their family in
their living conditions now this reminds me of
um a bible story that I was taught when I was
a young kid um about a guy called Esau who um
he was a very strong guy who was a hunter he was
the eldest son of his family and he was about to
get his inheritance; one day he came home very
very hungry really starving and his younger brother
I'm not sure his name Jacob maybe said to
himlisten I'll give you this food if you let me
take your inheritance and the guy was super
hungry so he gave it away and then you know in
in trade for being able to enjoy the moment he
lost his basically families wealth from from his
side of the family and this is the situation that
older people are finding themselves in now they
are seeing prices go up but at the same time their
house prices going up and they're thinking well
that's okay I'm making loads of money on the house
if I sell the house I can live a comfortable life
they of course grew up not in the asseteconomy
but in a workers economy and they think well
it's okay because my kids will be able to
work hard and buy properties of their own
in reality because we are in an asset economy
now when the older generation of the middle
class sell their property their kids and their
grandkids will never be able to buy property
again so what you see is as the richer get
richer and richer and richer more and more
of the middle class start to drop away as they
sell their assets to the rich and ultimately
inevitably if the rich are buying assetsthey
must be getting them from somewhere and
this is because people in the middle class are
dropping off so the way it affects you is that
we are moving into a world where if your family
has no assets they will never have assets
which means upper social mobility is becoming
impossible but increasingly as the rich get
richer and richer they take the assets of the
middle class which means inevitably my grandkids
and your grandkids (unless you are Rishi Sunak)
I don't know if you watch my videos
your grandkids will be poor so next we're going to
talk about how this looks from the perspective of
the old and the perspective of the young because
I think it looks very very different from both of
those perspectives now older people who in many
cases own property they often look at the asset
economy and they see their house price going up
and up and up and they think happy days you know
I'm really rich well done me for being so smart to
buy property I'm doing really really well um and
I use that money to to pay for their retirement
and they sell the property and they they live a
good life um and they think it's going to be okay
because they read stories in the newspaper saying
listen don't worry as long as your kids pull their
socks up and stop buying avocado toast and stop
going to Starbucks things will be fine um I think
it's really important for older people any older
people watching these videos any other people
in your life that you explain to them listen
if you sell that property which is the only way
you can actually enjoy the increase in house price
your kids and grandkids will never own property
that is what the asset economy is if you take a
long-term look at history you'll see for most of
history people born poor cannot ever buy assets
or property if you sell your property now as
we move back into asset economy your family
will be poor forever so older people who might
be happy at seeing house prices going up please
consider the consequence of this is poverty
foryour for your family for the rest of time
okay so how does it look from the perspective
of the young now this is something that I
really want to talk about because I think
it's really important now we still live
with this kind of age this idea in our
society that we live in a meritocracy
you know we we believe that if you work hard if
you save up if you study hard you can get rich
in reality as we move into the asset economy it
is increasingly difficult approaching impossible
for anybody born in a poor family to ever
become truly rich in the sense of owning assets
I think this creates a very very difficult
situation for the mental health of young people
we're telling young people listen if you don't
make money it's because you're lazy or because
you're dumb if you can't get rich it's because
you're lazy it's because you're dumb and we're
giving them a situation where if they're born into
the wrong family it is impossible for them to get
rich and why is it impossible for them to get rich
well the reason is like we've said before even if
you're earning a good salary imagine you're
earning 80 grand you have to pay tax on all
of your salary at the top end you're paying above
50% when you include National Insurance you save
up as much as you can after tax and you're able
to save maybe 10-15 grand a year when you go to
buy a property you are competing with young
kidsfrom richer families who are getting
gifts from their parents of 400,500,600 grand cash
that is the equivalent of you saving your after
tax income for 50 years even if you are on two or
three times the national average so we are telling
young people if you fail it's your fault and we
are making it impossible for them to succeed and
I think this is creating in many cases a mental
health crisis for young people so I want to send
the message out here to young people especially on
people from poor or ordinary backgrounds okay if
you are feeling like you are poor and other people
around you are rich that is not your fault you
have been given a system where it is impossible
for people born into poor families to get rich
so if you're not happy about that you need to come
and help us change the system you know that is
what this channel is here for if the system as it
is continues people from poor families will never
be able to escape poverty this is not your fault
this is a system that makes it impossible for you
support us and help us change that system now
the very last point which is something I think
that is super super interesting which is in the
asset economy for very sensible understandable
reasons people and families become very very
protective of their assets and that is because
if you are a family in an asset economy with no
assets your whole family your descendants forever
are consigned to definite poverty so obviously
you want to protect your assets as much as you can
because you know if you lose those assets then
your family is going to be devastated forever
and what that leads to is actually people
doing things which are actually very counter
their interests for example many people
because they are very protective of their
own assets will for example oppose things like
a wealth tax which we support on this channel
and once you understand the asset economy you can
totally understand why they're doing that they're
sitting there thinking oh my god if I lose these
assets then my family is going to be devastated
so I absolutely have to protect these assets
and in so doing they oppose increasing taxation
on the richest and remember that the wealth of the
richest is growing and growing and growing and if
you don't do anything about that it is inevitable
that they will out-compete the middle class for
assets in the long term it's a little bit like
if we're sitting here in this room and there's
a there's a massive balloon that is growing and
growing and growing at an accelerating rate and
it's starting to squash us all we're taking up
all the oxygen in the room and we're sitting
here with a little balloon in our pocket saying
we can't do anything that will hurt balloons
you see if you don't do anything about this
massively spiraling growing wealth of the
very rich remember just Rishi Sunak alone gets
a passive income of 40 million pounds they will
inevitably take all the assets in the long term
that means we will lose our middle class and
we will end up as a country which which is
filled with poverty the only way to protect
the middle class is to keep the wealth of this
country flowing through the country generation
after generation if you allow the rich to slowly
accumulate and grow and take all of the wealth
it is inevitable that ordinary families will lose
theirs in the long term but at the same time I'm
very understanding of why people want to protect
their wealth and that is why on this channel we
always make it very clear look we're not trying
to tax ordinary working people even if you might
be a doctor a lawyer or heaven forbid a banker
we are out here trying to tax very very wealthy
families with wealth of 10 100 a billion pounds
super super wealthy families these are the guys
who if you don't tax them their wealth will grow
and grow and over the long run they will end up
taking the wealth of the middle class so if you
allow the super rich to grow their wealth forever
unless you already are super rich you will lose
your wealth in the long run and your kids will be
poor the only way to protect working people in
this country including asset owners is to keep
wealth flowing around so listen I would encourage
you even if you do have wealth of your own you need
to support greater taxation of the rich and the
super rich if you do not then they will take
your wealth the only way to protect your wealth
is to stop the super wealthy from taking it and
if you allow them to accumulate more and more
wealth without paying any tax it is inevitable
that they will do that so I hope you enjoyed this
video the asset economy this is a theory which I
have used to help me understand the economy
for a long time I've made a lot of money of it
I think most economists don't understand
it if you understand it I think you have a
really good understanding what's happening most
important thing to understand it will get worse
asset prices will go up the rich will get richer
the middle class will become dispossessed and and
that includes you you know so I would encourage
you whether you are from a poorer background or
whether you are from a middle class background
support this channel get behind us support us
follow us and everything we've got what have we
got now TikTok, Facebook, Instagram, YouTube
of course, do you have anything else? yeah follow
it share this video because if we don't stop
this the situation gets worse I don't want it to
happen hopefully you don't want it to happen
if you are Rishi & you're watching these videos
thankyou for your support otherwise we need to
stop it, because its the only way to support
our futures and our families, thank you
money currently is Flowing from the
government to the rich leaving the
government with big powers of debt and the rich
with big parts of money there's one other thing
they can do with that mass amount of
income they can buy your mom's house
[Music]